I wanted to come down the way it came  down yeah yeah and and we're looking at  building seven here but in the case of  the Twin Towers the official narrative  tells us that the top part drove the  rest of the building down to the ground  sure and then destroyed itself well how  do you do that  um first of all that's not what happened  the top part is destroying itself in the  first four seconds you can see it in the  videos it's very clear the top part is  this the structural steel is actually  being liquefied if you will and and so  what happens after that by the way 156  First Responders are hearing explosions  this is in the oral histories uh  produced by Thomas vanesh and the fire  commissioner they're hearing explosions  uh before the tower ever collapses this  is research by Professor Graham McQueen  it's incredible  um and you wouldn't want that to be a  part of your story but you there's  certain things you can't get away with  when you're planning this event